I think he's sincere in the fact that he
really wants to find a wife Sean Lowe's
perfect advice for new bachelor Ben
Higgins the only thing I ever tell
people is look past the fancy dates and
like really look at the woman look at
her heart and see if you can imagine
yourself spending the rest of your life
with her he's got such a level head on
his shoulders he doesn't need my advice
just have fun with it all Sean is the
perfect former bachelor to share a few
helpful tips
he found drew love during season 17 of
the hit ABC show me and now wife
Katherine tied the knot in January 2014
and they're both hoping Ben finds the
one when his bachelor journey begins on
January 4th I think Ben is completely
sincere I think he's a great guy I think
he's looking for a good girl with good
morals
I think he's sincere in the fact that he
really wants to find a wife and so I
hope one of the 25 is a good match so he
can kind of join the married Club with
us all girls love to watch drama a
little bit but it's really about the
story and that's what I'm looking
forward to seeing Ben because he's gonna
lay it all out there and be sweet and be
honest and be